get oh okay all right
you inviting are we live
right I hope so we are alive no one no
one we're live I think we're alive oh
[ __ ]
tell me if we're live
I think we're alive guys weebs
we both
we've squatting
weebs where are they how's the guys
how's it going do we all have our energy
drinks ready for this discussion and Q a
I have mine I am I'm ready but
midoriya
you gotta save the world you can't you
can't be watching YouTube uh I think I
haven't I'm not caught up in my heroes I
don't know what's going on yeah me
neither me neither I don't watch it
how you doing Griffin how are you doing
down bloody veins my man how we do yeah
boys how are we doing let's all check in
check in with the peeps how we guys how
we guys doing how we doing guys
I am doing fairly well
good communication right there bobcat
just fine
uh according to my therapist I don't
have a therapist uh my marriage we start
with I feel statements
no it's scary it's great
um uh it's going great if you guys can
tell Griffin's uh video is not the
greatest quality I think it's
interesting oh it's not doing great
oh bad I don't understand what it looks
like
us Jesus Christ I'm sorry weebs I'm
sorry I I am very sorry I don't
understand
I went when there's great Wi-Fi gotta
get on that Asian connect connection am
I right
I don't know what's going on how's
everyone doing how's everyone doing
welcome yeah q a
first guys we were Griffin
what
great it's going great Griffin already
already broke I'm sorry guys I'm sorry
weebs discretion is happening here
eight months in the making guys eight
months but we're finally here we're
gonna chill with y'all for a long while
Daddy with powersuit Starkville exactly
it's really hot right now but it's worth
it how you guys doing
yeah it's interesting you didn't have
the AC on for a while you just got home
yeah I know so hot
you just wanted to shut up shut up
satisfied feline no way stay as long as
little as you like we're just gonna be
chilling here star kid
how's everybody
[Music]
I yeah he's a lot of YouTube stories too
damn I need I know star kid Phil hey
everybody here has to pressure Bobcat
into getting into YouTube stories at
some point it's been a year bro come on
yeah I'll do streams and you'll do uh
you'll do stories
fair play fair play would you rather eat
only cupcake rescue live or only eat
cupcake
only eat or eat or only eat only eat
what what's going on oh my goodness
Griff uh but yeah uh this is our first
uh let's do opening statements in a way
that
um why are we doing why are we doing uh
why are we doing the streams guys yeah
what are we doing it come on guys Focus
up Focus up because we want to hang out
with you peeps we want to hang out with
our peeps that's why when we want to
answer anime questions talk about anime
and all that fun stuff you know in the
videos and all that we don't get to talk
too much because we're on the clock we
gotta entertain we gotta satisfy we
gotta talk about anime and all that good
stuff so we don't really get a chance to
really chill out talk more get in depth
with you guys about our thoughts on
anime and everything else so like this
is kind of our way to you know when
we're not how to beating we're how to
questioning and answering ish so kind of
why we're doing this I guess
and I get to wear a suit come on no one
wears suits anymore what's going on
because uh
hottest balls I don't know yeah it's
actually really hot it's a three piece
too but yeah why are you wearing the
third piece you don't really see this
anymore yeah and I didn't realize the
frame was gonna be this tight anyways
I'll learn maybe I'll do it too I mean
still look good dumb you still look
dapper it's all good thank you hey
Beatrix how's it going uh imagine them
doing a how to beat Dragon Ball Z bro I
I wish but they're gonna they're gonna
take down the video so easy uh it's
super hard to do oh yeah those videos uh
Griffin's going down
slowly and slowly his camera is going
down somewhere
uh it's hard to do uh animes that's like
I said one piece Dragon Ball
and a couple other ones are have a have
a very tight copyright system where we
can't do anything this is a question I
want to ask for a long time between uh
uh I want to ask for a long time between
are you going to post more of me in
Abyss uh we just did the second season
so you can watch the last uh that was
the latest season that came out so you
guys can watch that one
uh yeah they made the maiden the best
movie was not the greatest I'll be
honest it was not not great
very little uh made in abyssing
if you know what I mean I mean you got
to set up the drama you got to set up
the story yeah I know it was a good like
character uh peace
I think it's good probably a smaller Arc
than they didn't want it to uh yeah
that's true the novel bonjour's a stud
I'm not gonna lie Isaac Clark wannabe
for sure
oh he's pretty messed up though
uh how much time does it take to
research an anime and no it really
depends to be honest man like it can
take a solid you know
20 minutes to like two hours for one
spot find out like how to beat it or at
least how to provide Insight in a way
that's still satisfying
you know because like there was one um
what was that uh devil man cry baby you
remember that Griff who's your favorite
anime we did
so literally actually the fun funny
thing we didn't tell Griff we were gonna
do uh devil man cry baby until like the
last minute because he had he did he did
not I thought he was cool as [ __ ] right
he probably thought I was like oh this
is probably cool and then he's just like
the last minute we're like yeah he
starts watching he's like what the [ __ ]
and it was too late by then like he was
already in the thick of it so that's how
we got to that's how we got him to do
devil man cry baby but not yet that was
one bit where like we uh it was we were
up against Satan towards the end of
Devilman crybaby and I was like bro how
do you defeat Satan like how do you
actually defeat Satan and I can't
remember what I wrote but basically yeah
basically sometimes you're up against
impossible odds so it's still important
to find out uh find a creative way to
comment critique or beat it but it's not
always about beating the situation
just fun fact if we can beat it we do
try yeah if you can but sometimes it's
hard man and I'm on the clock
uh is Devilman crybaby the only anime
the main character loses
oh that ending was so sad man God damn
um well I well I read a lot and usually
they don't really I mean sad endings I
mean death note technically the main
character loses uh what about I mean
berserk berserk they lose I mean he
loses pretty bad
I mean he still the story's ongoing it's
weird that berserk is still ongoing and
uh they're continuing picking up the
story again but
and he loses a lot but we haven't seen
him actually lose lose the story
actually ends with him losing right
um
uh question for Griff have you ever
auditioned for a voiceover for
grandchild impact
ignition impact
um I mean we did a brand deal with them
and have I ever auditioned for a gig
with them no I haven't uh I've seen gigs
around floating on various voice over
platforms I never really bothered with
it because at the time I was so busy I
was doing anywhere between 10 to 15
voiceover jobs a day I'm doing now maybe
like five or six on top of the how to
beat anime stuff but
well at the time I was so busy that
whenever I saw a gentian impact I was
like
I'm good
I got enough on my blade
uh oh Paul Deuces oh it's my boy poem
poem in the chat how's it going Thomas
Bobcat you recognize him yeah you just
talk soon
oh someone good good gamer said um you
have such a bitey face
who has a bitey face yeah is it Bobcat
oh everybody start calling Albert Bobcat
it's his nickname just so just call me
Albert Albee
hold on
gross you got to explain the story
no it's because Dom doesn't can't handle
calling people by their names because he
can't remember any name so he gives
everyone a [ __ ] he gives everyone a
nickname he calls me Chief bobcat and
then [ __ ] oppa because I have like a
bleached hair once a while ago and he
keeps forgetting everyone's else's name
and keep reusing the same nickname right
and now it just stuck with him he loves
Bobcat no I don't but all right so yeah
Vin Diesel in the chat family my man Dom
Toretto we love you
yeah Griffin has 1440p 14-4 rev why do
you keep shrinking man what's going on
no I don't know
do not know
I don't know
couldn't fools I there's upsetting
yeah I know right it isn't adorable no
it's not fit two
stop [ __ ] love you too
okay YouTube series yes
yes I will I would love that YouTube
series of bobcat bob cut or stories uh
not gonna Albert or Bob cut is the best
at explaining the animes
yeah of course I am
hahaha
it's funny Jane saw man when chainsaw
man when it ends never when the series
ends and when we can start working on it
we could do it uh China is great uh
great manga great series how would you
rather be in Naruto or the rest of your
life or be in one piece the rest of your
life
um Tom which one would you be you know
probably don't know any of these two all
right shut up I'll be Naruto because I
played the PSP game and I was okay you
you did play Naruto yeah I did it was
pretty good good how about you Griffin
uh um no no no nope not so much I
watched it but I never
uh which one do you want to be Naruto or
live in Naruto in one piece
I would
character
um
I
you know what
I would like to be
hmm that's tough which world do you want
actually I probably have to you have to
you don't have to be the main character
I don't know
no no I don't know I'm undecided
I'd see
my mouth fell down
what else yeah
all right so Grifton really answer and
took 10 minutes okay next one
I didn't no I wasn't sure ow means
Bobcat what feline is Domin Griffin you
know I gave everybody all the nicknames
in the world nobody ever gives Dom a
nick if you want if you guys want to
call me the weeb king or Goldfinger see
because you're not right here
I don't know whatever you guys want to
call it something not cute you want to
be called like I said call me Ace call
me right
oh this is a bobcat question from
Starkville
in your Trio who's the narrative to
Sasuke and Sakura uh Griffin the Sakura
foreign
uh-uh
nah
I don't know I'm Sakura usually I'm very
support in the back
dog's very Sasuke Griffin's more Naruto
nice area Gallup Gotta Get It Right emo
boy uh
I mean all right anything other than
weep King is great for me no stop hey
it's gonna become a thing it's not a
thing
[Music]
favorite series we made
um what's favorite series you know I
would oh series oh no any favorite video
you guys make which one do you guys
would you guys uh actually actually like
I need a sec
everyone
um
probably
which one
okay I'll give a couple
um uh favorite one probably might think
Geo is one of a favorite of mine
um and let's see eyelid of giant SX
because that was my first one
uh how to beat anime and then probably
really liked Higurashi story was all
over the place but I like that one
I would say
um Geo Mr shite had no idea what was
happening it was one of the first things
we did uh High School the dead because
guys I mean even though I'm the weeb
king I'm not like
anime is still I'm getting used to it
but High School of the Dead was one of
those uh fun fact I love zombies love
zombie games zombie movies zombie videos
Netflix [ __ ] Resident Evil whatever so
High School of the Dead combine anime
and zombies and it was just an
all-around fun time loved it from start
to finish it's not and I was just it's
not yeah it's not the best but it's just
like that sounds it's awesome but it's
also a lot of like fun and Camp it's
like I think it's like a lot of camp
I think it could be not he could be it's
probably a lot of sexual tension in that
[ __ ] job just a smidge just a smidge
it's really hard to like you know
cut a lot of that that stuff out
uh did you guys think about beauty water
how about that huh oh Beauty water man
it was the shade
it was good because it was like it was
such a simple Story one you know a
couple of four characters Max and it was
a movie really short movie so it really
gave you time to like flush out every
single scene and really get into like
the thick of it and put more like Bells
bells and whistles on on it a lot of
time with anime if it's like 12 episodes
you're spending a lot of your time
trying to get from episode one episode
two episode three and trying to
you know compact it all into a 25 a
minute you know video but with beauty
water it was so simple and there was not
a lot of stuff to keep it to keep track
of story wise that it really like
allowed me to you know just like [ __ ]
take my time have some fun with it so I
loved it and of course the ending was
sick pretty boy such a minute
now I never read the webtoon but did it
deviate at all from the webtoon let us
know in the chat
um did a stick to it and stick to it a
little bit the main bad guy wasn't as
a big deal wasn't the biggest deal uh
but I think the mainline story is that
uh the girl wanted to be beautiful
and then she I think everything went
downhill I think the main story is the
same I think the bad guy was just like
uh like a random passing kind of guy
that also it's like a serial killer type
but you know uh but I think they weaved
it better in the movie so people it's
more cohesive right because every and a
movie needs to be concise and cohesive
what cartoon should have been an anime
my favorite Netflix zombie movie is
alive I know you guys would love it oh
alive that was good [ __ ] I remember that
a zombie see another zombie movie bro
great stuff [ __ ] Korean Cinema makes
great zombie movies on [ __ ] bangers
Korean Cinema is going up and up yeah
that's true Griffin's already uh lagged
out so oh God damn we're gonna start
getting failed my chemical dominance
great name and bloody veins no [ __ ]
worries bro just keep watching and keep
chilling out with us you know no worries
no pressure
uh how to be erased uh a bit erase is
good a race is pretty good it's a murder
mystery I it could be a good man it
could be a good video
um yeah we 2K zappy what's up
hi how's it going meowing 2K how's it
going everyone here hope everyone's
doing great they're doing great
uh but yeah if you guys have any other
questions you guys want to talk about or
we can we can just chat uh chat about
anything honestly got the shite that's
true
uh shoot crabs I don't know okay what I
want to know people in the channel let
me know did you watch Beauty water and
if so did it resonate with you because I
feel like it was a story that would
resonate with a lot of people you know
what I mean because
I think it would probably resonate with
you because
[Laughter]
look at that [ __ ] potatoes potato
potato camera what the [ __ ] oh my God
Bobcat is feisty I like it got the paws
out today you know what I mean mm-hmm
uh I think it resonated with a lot a lot
of people right uh going back to sirius
it is our first uh it's also our first
Dream honestly uh it's been eight months
in the process guys to get to here even
though it's just this eight months eight
months bro I mean keeping track
crazy it's been insane
it's been going crazy I hope you guys
are enjoying the channel I hope we had a
crazy start of the channel
if you guys don't know we started what a
year ago a year probably a year in
couple of months ago a month yeah and uh
we thought it wasn't gonna be big we
thought it was probably like probably
get a couple of views here and there we
were remember though and we just started
uh I texted Tom every day I was like oh
[ __ ] we got monetization oh [ __ ] two
dollars
yeah oh [ __ ] 200 views [ __ ] yeah I was
so excited that's true man
I was in shock I couldn't believe it
but the one I was so not sure about Geo
because that one like exploded and I was
just like
that's true I was really nervous for
that one
I think for a week for like I think I
think actually like maybe three months
into it
I didn't like tell anybody
um because like I was scared that we
would crash and burn within three months
every week I'd be like [ __ ] I gotta do
another script man you know I got really
nervous but you know now I'm the weed
king so I'm getting there
can't even tell what Naruto or one piece
is I don't know what Naruto is what's
one piece it's that thing you know I saw
one time
oh is that one step what is that one
thing
[Laughter]
uh what anime are you doing next should
we tell people it's gonna be probably
released in a couple of days right
what's up we'll keep it to the end we'll
keep it we'll tell you guys which one
we're gonna do next this week
hmm
well I just was finally able to get to
that chat log thing was not showing up
for me so now I can actually see all the
people's comments whoa whoa oh good nice
nice nice what anime are we doing next
we can't tell you but you guys will like
it it's a continuation on some of the
animes we've done so you know you guys
don't have to wait 10 more months I saw
the maiden Abyss comments guys we can't
just release Maiden Abyss part one and
part two just like that we gotta like
spread out you know spread out the love
keep you guys guessing a little bit you
know what I mean the next video is not
it's not a second part and I'll see the
next video no but like the next few
videos like it's kind of a you know
continue you know you know you know
maybe not the next one actually I forgot
what the next one is I'm so far I'm so
far ahead guys come on but yeah no you
just don't want to kill yourself from
watching anime so much
you guys got to understand Dom watches
so much animes along we all do but when
he's watching he's like I'm dying he's
like one of these things you guys should
actually take a photo and screenshot off
Dom's Netflix page it's all
Survivor Island yeah we can't do that
Bachelorette dating in Brazil goddamn
yeah I like watching daily podcast soon
okay
but yeah
when I'm not watching anime which is
also
which I love
it's cool how far this channel has come
look at uh more looks like more people
enjoy hypotheticals than I thought
can you guys do chainsaw man I will
probably do it when the series is done
uh when this not the manga is here is
but the the season one of anime the
anime probably will start putting in
that in the schedule but currently it's
not done but tomb two is it is that out
can anyone tell me if that's out or not
I think Batum just there's only one
platoon right uh they didn't make a
second season
uh yeah they only have no clue man I
have no clue either anime brain rot
that's us that's how we usually work
it's
oh one piece what do you have to order
how to beat
it's a joke dog
we need to [ __ ] shut up
I have a crush on the guy in Black you
have a new person who's crushing on you
though oh thank you
so awkward I mean it really is no
competition once he's wearing a suit
it's done it's like
right it's the only time I get to wear a
suit
bring back suits only time you get aware
is pretty that's pretty sad if you
anyway well you know whatever [ __ ]
office culture these days is so chill
you know you don't wear a suit in office
unless you're a [ __ ] Wall Street I
know I know I know
do 100 series on how to be one oh my God
have you guys watched JoJo is it on your
list
uh it's on our list but I think it's
down further down our list it's a lot
JoJo's a lot it's hard we're gonna get
murdered by the fan fan base when we do
and we [ __ ] up a joke or we [ __ ] up
something oh [ __ ] now we're good we're
good we're good
that's one thing that like it's taking
me a while to get used to is
because I take Liberties when I write
the stuff and like I give everybody
nicknames and all that stuff but
sometimes I give the wrong person a
nickname and then like the comments
sometimes they're like you know why
don't you [ __ ] keep him in the
original like as the original name and
[ __ ] and I'm like God damn it no problem
is you sometimes call people with brown
hair red hair I was like what the heck
foreign
purple hair that girl's hair is blue as
[ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
we're going to do a hunter video are we
gonna do a hunter hunter video uh well I
drew you it was oh send that to the um
anime IG I want to see that I want to
see how you drew Bobcat I drew you it
was so hard what did you did you get the
whiskers the Bobcat the what do you mean
what did you do
would be cool
it's a lot of weird it's
absolutely no I don't know if the script
comes and you don't have to tell what
the title is probably you probably do it
absolutely
um how many how many animes are on our
currently working on the list we got
quite a few to be honest Bobcat is
always like he's like doing pretty good
with the whole list of [ __ ] right uh we
got
we have three scripts we're like three
scripts ahead you're working on a third
script the next one will announce at the
end of the stream which would be cool uh
which is a good one I think it's a good
one we had to work on it a lot this week
what I know we have a part two of
something else and we have a new series
that we're starting
well one of the ones I want to do was
Hunter Hunter but I don't know if that's
I need to look into it a little bit more
I don't know we'll see happy sugar life
it's a psychological horror I'll put
that on the list that sounds sick
actually
Bobcat is like our fun fact he like
he watches the anime but he also reads
it or like the manga and [ __ ] like he's
seen literally everything or some [ __ ]
so like everything all right so like if
I'm the weed King he's like the
oh I don't know I don't really know weed
Queen I guess oh okay you're my queen
I'll let you call yourself the king
because I let you because I'm too good
it's pretty nice
what is this oh my gosh what else you're
seriously how to beat Corpse Party
didn't we do uh
yeah yeah I remember that man I wish we
just that was that the game we just did
the actual game because the uh the TV
show didn't make any sense it really
didn't bro
very good
oh you know what
a lot of anime doesn't make sense I'm
the same as me what hey bloody veins my
man I'm gonna call you Bobcat too what
about that time I reoccur into a slime
that'd be a lot of fun but I think it's
hard to do like a lot the ones that are
actually just fully action right
um
uh how that time I reincarnated into a
slime
where the main character died and got
reincarnated into a slime that's the
title
I talked about it before
a while ago where oh yeah uh where
novels uh oh the specific like yeah we
talked about like animes or mangas or
whatever with very specific
um titles looks like that one I really
like the
the really funny one I kidnap girls is
it weird is it weird that I picked
little girls in a dungeon is it weird to
try and kiss girls in a dungeon yeah I
was like Brooke who comes up with this
stuff oh you said you were gonna get a
poster for that my friend actually for
his birthday I actually got him a whole
thing
I know I know the weeb king's got to
give you know something
[Laughter]
movie adaptation what
um bloody veins yes
one of anyone corpse princess what's
corpse princess
bob cut Bobcat corpse princess I'll take
it though uh meow 2K who's asking hi Zoe
hello hello I'm gonna look it up orps
for instance that sounds kind of nice
actually riddle Story of Evil I'm gonna
look that up
I keep keep notes of the the riddle the
devil riddle and the all that good stuff
these sound pretty good actually
sound interesting I'm checking out right
now
no we're gonna oh it's actually a
different word it's called Uh redo of a
Healer
uh no
no no I'm back God damn it God damn it
[ __ ] I'll get it my man how did this
happen why why did everything
I don't know why we went live
uh someone said that we should do like
how to beat gaming I think we it's one
of those things we want to do but it's a
lot of work
[Music]
we'll do it for something special I
changed my name into Bobcat I'm bloody
face I see the same I see the name
it's the same I honestly love it though
respect
got a wonderful comment from Eric
Benedict I really appreciate the work
you guys are doing I don't have the time
or attention span to watch the actual
movies or TV series but your breakdowns
in the videos give me a way to watch
thank you oh welcome thank you Eric very
nice I didn't realize that was a thing
like people like if they're too busy
whatever they still want to watch movies
or anime or whatever but then they'll
watch like some sort of recap thing like
I didn't know that was like a thing
honestly
sounds like a sauce as hell bro
what I was gonna say I'm not gonna I
don't that sounds sauce
what's the weirdest anime you recommend
making everyone watching uh oh dear
there's a there's an anime that's super
weird but super fun it's a comedy anime
called something I can remember
pleasure to have you bro it's Saint
young man
what's up and higarashi was really weird
uh Saint young man is really fun it's
really weird because it's basically a
story about how Jesus and Buddha got a
shared apartment in Japan wait what's it
called what's it called Saint young man
saint of Nissan wait wait wait wait yeah
I got one I got one I got one I got one
I got one I got one remember isn't like
my uncle lives in my apartment it's like
another weird long title oh that one's
also great that's that's on Netflix I
think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
should we do that one that was a lot of
fun it's weird I don't think that'd be
fun to do for something yeah I do
yeah I did that I have seven exams and
I'm watching you guys bad Bobcat we're
gonna seven exams what are you doing
goats oh my God School thought of it
it's starting to get it's trying to
learn how to do nen because he's he's
trying to do the hunter exam
JoJo Bizarre Adventure out of it one of
these days we'll do JoJo Bizarre
Adventure
all right shut up Ryder wolf
hey garage is hella weird we gotta do we
gotta finish out hikarashi we just did
half of the series that's true
that's pretty good actually I like that
it was just
very weird though yeah very confusing
there's a lot there's a lot in the
series we can do a lot more honestly
it's like and when we did the main video
I was like reading comments and people
were like I don't know which story arc
to follow or where to which order
because there's like so many Loops of
the same thing but in different ways
was just like very it was it was
confusing for sure there's like two
seasons no not two three four there's
like a lot there's like five or
something there's a lot in anime one
piece in 35 minutes God damn you gotta
get now bro
gotta stop huffing some having paint my
guy started Phil this is now a study
tutorial stream for Bobcat
for Bobcat
hell yeah hmm
well the other
uh I like everyone's embracing the
feliness I hate
I'm never coming back how to beat 100
tails
out of the undertale
we're gonna get [ __ ] by the community
undertale community have you guys not
never seen have you guys heard of
underneath no it sounds scary I don't
know
uh it's a It's like a
only computer no it's on Console also
it's like a game that was inspired by
Earthbound and this one guy created it
where you can do basically two runs oh
two to three runs of the game which is
you can be like a nice guy where you
don't even fight an enemy or you can
actually just destroy everything because
apparently if you kill enemies they
[ __ ] run out
so it's not it's not Random Encounters
they actually run out and they don't
just be a monster in their eyes
but yeah this is a game it's a game it's
called undertale it's a good game
uh my Chilean friend and me recreate the
ending of this anime on our with our OCS
all right
nice
the other two game is very cool I have
speed run why are you speed running a
story game
it's probably a fast I'm actually really
curious
there's so many
there are so many Aus uh uh the nice
guys Frisk and her sister's car is the
bad guy
okay I know nothing about this one I'll
leave that one to buy I also I am also
lost I don't remember any of their names
I shouldn't have said anything about
undertale all right my mistakes
uh no blundertale you play as the green
God what what
what's going on can we talk about beauty
water please
Beauty water that's great
beard water is a great anime on it to
watch
it
is
it's pretty crazy though like one of the
things I wonder about like think about
it so if this business for beauty water
they charge about 200 000 for like what
a pack of was it six to eight bottles
right ish that's a lot of money
like jeez so then I was thinking about
this I was like wait a minute what's
like really expensive beauty stuff so
like I did the Google I looked up some
stuff could spend fifty thousand dollars
for a b Venom facial
that's pretty sick
some people will just do anything to be
beautiful am I right
are you looking at yourself so what
you're doing
I'll do that
no no
it's gonna be nice to be like you no no
you don't need a b Venom facial
he just did like he just looked at
himself and did an underbite which is
weird
I don't know
uh
that's also a good like anime good anime
not good anime it's a good good how to
beat light not not how to be it's a game
but the game goes weird I think uh not
weird in a way that goes creepy as [ __ ]
uh it could be something that we do one
of these days if we actually play uh if
you actually do a gameplay of it
will they ever make an enemy of it maybe
it's official novel
uh beautiful is probably my favorite
story that webtoon series I love reading
the chapters late at night the web 2
Series great it's something horror it's
a great web to if people want to watch
it they have a sequel of beauty water
they do as a webtoon yeah
it's very weird where apparently because
apparently in the in the original one
the beauty water isn't permanent
uh as in the movie the movie Made made
it more permanent in a way that's like
oh it's like the reason why she lost all
her stuff was because of the
the beauty water or she [ __ ] it up or
something
um
that's that's in a movie but in the
manga it was like it was like a
defective with defective product so you
have to reuse it you have to redo redo
reuse and some people makes more sense
get people hooked and then you know
take all the cash
I mean it freaked me out though and for
the anime of beauty water you know we
got pretty boy you know Don with all his
uh nicknames hey boy and he's like all
these eyeballs and like lips and faces
on him from smearing the beauty water of
his victims on himself and I'm just like
oh this is intense
one of these days we got to get like
some merch that says like I got glasses
guy energy or like I want to grow up to
be like pretty boy or something with
like how to be or something you know
like oh my God that would be sick
would be good great I've been trying to
make it a thing guys you don't
understand like
these guys have to tell me repeatedly
things because I have the attention span
of a flea like we want this to be a
thing I'm like like no no no we want
this to really be a thing so now he has
like big bold and highlight in yellow
he's like
I want this to be a thing glasses guy
energy so now now I finally got it no I
finally remember
yeah how's it going uh I I gift the
beauty water to my enemies yeah to get
them hooked on like that'll be actually
great
yeah
oh
[ __ ] Griffin's [ __ ] up yeah
I know I know is the quality still um
oh still bad I don't understand it is so
weird like
Jim just stayed home like geez I go
somewhere else that actually has great
Wi-Fi for all y'all don't know I live in
the middle of nowhere truly the middle
of nowhere
and the one internet provider that I got
is like
arable so I don't I don't buy it
and so I come here to this much nicer
spot with great Wi-Fi and the video is
horrible oh I'm so sorry
you should you should be sorry we'll get
better as time goes on we'll work out
the The Kinks and uh all that all that
good stuff
for sure
oh my gosh the boys are together
hilarity will come about this I'm sure
goddamn right it will God damn what do
you say oh the boys
hopefully it's something funny happens
uh
I know theological introspection I know
my internet I know but it's weird you
got me to understand
the owner of the Dawn wait I've heard of
that
we I don't think you know that one hey
like you Junior
I'm gonna do blood see Bobcat write that
down blood C it is on the list I can't
remember oh [ __ ] nice on our list yeah
hell yeah oh that's a vampire one in it
yeah it is totally is but are you guys
enjoying the video are you guys enjoying
the stream I hope you're doing great
uh
I hope you're enjoying yourself
not in a weird way but enjoying that
weird
that made it weird but now that I've
clarified it now that you brought it up
now that I clarified it made it a little
bit weird
um how about you have you guys do have
you guys been doing anything fun lately
uh Dom Griffin
like Hobbies what we talk about I don't
know anything like something fun to talk
about anything fun guys
uh on these days I'm pretty boring I do
the same old hodgepodge you know
um
ah been exploring Bangkok a little bit
you know checking out the the fun spots
to visit you know just uh the night you
know nightlife and just getting used to
you know
yeah pretty much it
as in uh McDonald's where it's sometimes
slithering around town
he's like God you don't understand
sometimes we'll be on a phone call me
and Dom and he'll be like yo Griff so
blah blah blah here's the deal about
this the next script we're doing I'm
like okay great and he's like so uh
should I stay out I'm like what time is
it like ah it's 4am I'm like go to sleep
he's like I'll Slither around town a
little more I'll do a little more
slithering yeah sometimes we have to
discuss
it's gonna be on the prowl there we go
sometimes we have to discuss like work
calls while we're like you know on you
know on patrol fighting crime and all
that so sometimes
I don't have to say your name I'm sorry
hi everyone uh JK what
uh and then you said oh can you guys do
a q a yeah
if anyone has a question you can shoot
it and if we see it we can answer it
yeah that's right I was like if you guys
want to know uh Griffin's social
security number you can
true
because I have everything Maybe
cute magical anime was quite the shark
is that a how to beat
that's that one
did we
we did something
there's another one oh yeah yeah
there's another one that's like also
similar but not the same
as time has gone on we've gone we've
done like we've been able to do less
obvious horror type stuff and we've been
able to like Branch out into a little
bit less horror stuff but still try and
make it you know juicy and terrifying so
I don't know
got a lot of good animes out there
it's true that are not necessarily
horror that maybe we can do I don't know
see what am I doing anything fun well
see I'm just doing a lot of
a lot of doctor appointments not for me
from her wife
that's my wife we got another kiddo on
the way so it's fun but I got a lot of a
lot of doctor appointments that's what
I'm doing so I'm sorry I'm boring
nerd
nerd
anime stuff you're asking you're saying
I'm a nerd I know what you're talking
about you can't see the Hatsune Miku
over there
my gosh does she call me Baka actually
one time one time ever as a joke she
looks she goes back out
nice
sad though she watches ahead of me she's
like
it's like oh [ __ ] she said that oh yes
damn
Griffin is married yeah yeah you're
balling chain
yeah yeah
he's a big man doing big man things
thank you thank you meowing 2K I love
you thank you thank you
thank
you
um Bobcat You Gotta Get Married Too come
on chop chops
how about you how are you looking in the
mirror and get married
how about we get very dumb as if as a
bear
we can like film it for Content we can
do it
like April fools like how to beat
like how to beat marriage or something I
can do a thing uh oh that'd be funny
run we'll speed on our marriage into
divorce
congrats if you call if she calls you
Baca she's a keeper
one time one time ever she she did I was
like yes okay to be fair to be fair
he does like Attack on Titan he thought
Death Note the anime was interesting
okay that's something normal [ __ ] I mean
it's still good enough it's good
oh no do it what question do you have
there's it give us the question
is
[Laughter]
oh he would have fish ER guys's wedding
star kid would do your guys that's cute
Mrs me buddy uh how does one survive uh
when we get divorce on the series you
want a serious answer do you want like
uh as long as you get one of those what
is it the paper the contract I can't
remember the English well I think it's
like a prenuptial a prenup prenup yeah
you can beat the marriage anytime
all right so you got this or annulment
if you hadn't consummate the marriage
then you're gonna know hey
that's the worst part you don't uh Delta
so I probably don't I'll murder Dom
Ain stop me
oh my gosh his watches guys you don't
understand this guy has a sickness we
should make like a petition with his
watches
this is actually an intervention for
Dom's obsession with watches all right
that's nice
you gotta tell the time gotta be
punctual you know yeah how many watts do
you need for that
um well you know one for like water you
know when it's raining and then one for
like when you're wearing the suit you
know the watch gotta be like a certain
millimeter of thickness so it fits under
the cuff you know there's a lot of like
you know things you need watch you know
different you know yeah
let's see well okay guys you don't
understand so he loves watches so much
he'll send us a picture he's like guys
look at this watch it's Swiss made and
I'm like it says Made in French
French design Swiss made I don't know it
said made in French but all right
I think if we were baby girl you have it
you have to have your watch nearby where
is it oh it's on my wrist oh my there it
is
wait oh nice guys he's got a magic trick
he's got a magic trick for this okay
ready do your magic trick for the watch
you got it oh no I was with the other
one I can't I can't do it with this one
you can't do it
why do you have a watch to not do the
magic trick all right here's another now
we're gonna save that's actually a good
idea group I'm writing that down into
our next stream we're gonna do it the
magic trick I
my video will be better too I promise I
I don't understand what that deal is
I just don't have a message for us think
of your baby uh yep for sure I I do not
plan on getting divorced I'm I'm very no
we're talking about me and uh Dom Mr
big-headed Right Down
that's not even about you Griff
in
it's you were you're our baby that's
basically what it meant I think that's
fair all right go study science I can
like a good
student
oh bobcat
um
he left yeah he should start you gotta
study bro he's gotta pass then he can
watch anime what's our Rosario plus
vampire is that a good good anime
anyways it's it's you know
what is it like high school the dead for
you or something devil man cry baby type
[ __ ] it's not as uh overt I would say as
High School of the Dead but it it makes
his high school the Dead with vampires
basically that sounds sick as [ __ ] man
why don't we do that
write that down
all right A lot of it are written and we
just don't have the time ah Fair player
you got a 98 on your report sounds fake
hey there you go what what way to go oh
damn calling him out
it's a parametamine but a guy in a
monster school and a lot of monsters are
trying
that sounds pretty good to be honest
it's pretty good
isn't there one called Monster musume or
something where ah
oh yes yes I there's a guy who lives in
the dormitory and there's like monster
girls that living with him and the Only
Rule that he that he's allowed to do he
can stay in the dormitory because that's
the only one that he can stay in for
price wise but he can't [ __ ] the girl or
something
you can't date them or something I can't
remember oh
thought the monster must whatever it was
called I thought that was didn't she a
snake lady or a snake thing yeah it's a
lot of weird things snake lady slime
lady
there's a centaur lady
uh
continue with the rest of werewolf gave
werewolf games that's a question for how
to beat or
uh Cinema summary yeah previously called
Twitter summary
and we'll have to ask him if they do
they're gonna do it if they do Anatomy
we'll do it how to beat seven deadly
sins that's out of that's not a horror
that's an action anime
you could work it could work I'm not
gonna do it just because season three
sucks but
have you not seen season three or the
memes of it
oh it's the worst
um Mia the lamia yeah he gets into a
program to have monster girls at his
house to have better rations but he
can't do something right
he's not allowed to date them or he's
not allowed to be in a relationship with
them
I might be like connecting other hair
among together
Sweden
Garuda oh
you both [ __ ] try this
where were you at Dom where was the you
should tell them the snow story you know
with your foot
oh yeah so okay
Benjamin uh Sweden one time I was in
Sweden and they were like everybody
everybody loves [ __ ] cross-country
skiing or something at least when I was
there right and they were like let's try
it out and I'm like all right sure so we
started doing it and my laces but my
boots while we were on the skis they
were on they were untied right but I was
too lazy to sit down in the cold ass
snow and tie them up so I was just like
ah you know it's fine whatever so we
started like cross-country skiing and
ship and then a couple hours later I'm
like my foot is kind of cold right now
and then I looked down I tried to like
tie my shoes but the laces were kind of
Frozen and I was like ah it's fine
whatever so then like eight more hours
passed by and then it was like a whole
day thing and then my foot was really
starting to like [ __ ] flare up it was
like really hurting and I was like what
the [ __ ] is going on so by the end of it
um
I went back to the hotel or whatever and
I took off my shoe my foot had like
expanded like four times man and I was
like you know what this this is not good
but the one thing that'll solve it is
like hot water in like the shower so I
turned up the heatness of the water to
like full hotness dump that [ __ ] in
there the worst mistake of my life I was
in so much pain but the next day it went
away but I had never once thought that I
had like a frostbite so thankfully I
didn't think about it because I would
have probably cried my foot's good
though so don't know always tired always
tie your laces when cross country skin
all right go to bed Uno thank you for
coming thank you for everyone who's okay
bye thank you for joining us we're not
going yet we're not going yet we're not
going yet guys guys I got like four
energy drinks two green teas one water I
was supposed to get a coffee but my
coffee Shop's closed so I'm in it for
the long haul you know I'm right here
hell's thing
's good
yep the whole thing is good what else
thing I feel like we'd have to be really
creative about it though because I mean
it's a vampire thing she was like you
know all the typical vampire stuff happy
like which how we off them which vampire
movie uh anime yeah let's see I'll sing
yeah oh okay it's good uh we saw that we
got a 2004 movie with a Hugh Jackman
classic I literally didn't know that it
was Hugh Jackman when I watched that all
right
Hugh Jackman Kate back in sale I think
Daryl from Walking Dead's in it Norman
Reedus has like The Tech Guy
oh the
yeah the dude the monk guy supplies him
with the the texture yeah
it's also a good one
you can't touch the girls but he touched
them all the time
yeah honestly I'm assuming he can't
touch the girls yeah uh Bobcat write
down this monster masumi thing
you [ __ ] how in the world is this how
to beat
get your [ __ ] right Griffin
[Laughter]
brilliant
oh my God the anime not the movies
I know I know I know at the end I mean
the enemies I've seen it
uh I do want to do
Alucard Castlevania
Castlevania is that the Netflix one yeah
Netflix one I want to do that one hmm
sounds good
oh Helsing ultimate is better okay it'll
have to do that one instead
coverage oh Philippine horror anime
Bobcat can I say that's also good that's
like a supernatural kind of horror anime
yeah
come down and try that good write that
right I'm gonna write that down Bob kid
you're so good at writing stuff down
though yeah
Trace got it boom Oh You Gotta Buy you
got a Griff got it cool cool
I don't know when we'll do it but we
probably will it's on the list it's on
the list
see
your surviving monsters and creatures in
another dimension their side picnic I'm
looking it up how to beat uh
casa
wait let me write this write it down
written by Yori melzawa illustrated by
okay
interesting
thank you for the suggestion let's have
to add that one too I think stream can
hear what I'm hearing I shouldn't watch
uh trailers while I do this very naughty
Bobcat I mean
what's up I couldn't hear that what
about supernatural oh Supernatural also
has an anime did you have an anime
it's a weird it's a weird I think they
have it for a season
that is funny
I'm checking this out
oh they do I'll be darn hmm how many
episodes is that is it like late or
early right now in the world where
everybody's at it's the entire episode
what the [ __ ]
but foreign
[Laughter]
interesting
start get fell we're gonna make it
happen just you watch
midnight here I'll be in the next story
hey there you go tonight Phil thanks for
joining us bro thank you everybody
uh never
I'll be in YouTube stories never ever
you can join me in the Stream stuff
hey
I'll be interested
could work
work
yeah we'll do it one of these days it'll
be fun
meow 2K to 11AM oh [ __ ] nice
there you add meowy 2K don't give
specifics don't get darks
because
remember address I'm the only one who
can say I'm in mango Town Bangkok baby
don't worry I'm in your basement
oh yeah oh yeah uh Jensen Ackles only
voiced Dean for the last episode that's
a weird thing to do
the show called The Boys which is a
[ __ ] great yeah he plays uh
Captain America ripoff spin-off whatever
sort of yeah in the YF he watched only
one one episode like okay yeah not for
us no it's such a good show it's that's
really good bro it's such a good Story
season three you'll love it or is it the
latest one what is it yeah
that is totally up your alley man uh for
you should I think I I think it's too
much work Griffin season three
it's gonna blow his brain
I've heard of things when yeah my other
voice over gigs sometimes they'll be
like oh what's the top ten this the top
ten this or different shows so I know
little Snippets and then when I heard I
had to voice a bit about like what was
it a hero gasum is that what it was
that's like reading this I'm like what
oh like
uh the heroes have uh Orchard
hell yeah no no
uh how to beat street hmm
I think I wrote that down actually you
wrote it down okay nice thank you Tom
thank you his name is homelander if I
remember correctly no uh Jensen Ackles
didn't play homelander I think Eric
something star or played Anthony Starr
played homelander Hollander is [ __ ]
sick he's such a good character yeah
that's true anyone watch which play the
comics I heard are underrated I like the
anime series from back then I better
look it up
have you guys been watching anime uh
audience audience we were your boo
members
that's what you're watching right now
[ __ ] I'm writing that down thank you
black ice
thank you
a video are you watching
rule five black ice
are you watching let me know
hey welcome four or five black guys
girl
oh School live don't we Tony uh we might
do I think we'll probably do that
survival zombie come on you can't not do
it I've done another zombie since uh
what was it uh High School station oh
[ __ ] it's been like a year or something
there's a lot of good ones recently
well we can take a bad one and I'll make
it good right and call they call me
Goldfinger for a reason
no no one calls you ghosts
emo boy okay story behind that guys like
Dom sends us a picture you know we're
really happy with how you know
video those amazing business I was like
we're really happy with it and he's like
hey I'm going to like send us a picture
of his hand he's like I'm gonna insure
these bad boys they're gonna be gold
fingers fingers of gold so whatever
story behind that
exactly
for sure
man they really like one piece huh one
of these are great
it's good but it's long oh it's long as
bowls
vows no we did please
also a zombie oh yeah that's true isn't
season two uh
I think a movie's coming out
that was pretty good combinary yeah that
was very like snow piercer and zombies
coming together right that was the good
one yeah
that was fun I love what you did with
the
video stuff I love what you did with
kabanero I love when you put like the
yellow attacks the text in behind the
video and stuff oh I love that that was
so cool I can't remember it's been a
while
that's been a little while
a little bit
see
yeah
I don't know if it's gonna be I don't
know if the films are connected or
something
which thousand year blood oh yes I
haven't watched it yet the new bite that
downgrade write that down
which one oh bleach a thousand year
blood War and uh the other psycho three
no it's um please uh [ __ ]
oh okay
we can do probably the most like is fun
uh bleach is also like 100 episodes like
400 500 episodes okay you know
[Laughter]
when I write that down when I write it
down yeah I got it I got it oh we should
do it
pretty good
uh Covenant has a great concept I hope
to see more stuff they're they're doing
a movie
yeah I'm excited
I think so they're doing a movie I don't
know if it's out yet
a movie sequel or something
oh
how to beat Bucky
I could be fun I love the visuals of
that all the fighting it's really fun
yeah
uh
um that seems so inauthentic because
like none of us are Fighters at least
maybe I don't might be a fighter I'm
kidding
uh uh Valkyrie like the the fighting one
that the God one I can't remember what
it's called
Matsu Falcon I can't remember
new anime 2023 Tokyo records of Ragnarok
oh my God Jesus Christ yes
records of Ragnarok so so great it's
basically humans thumb this is the pitch
all right hit me let me um sell it to me
the gods wants to destroy Earth Gods are
like Thor Zeus like everyone
um
every every type of God is there and
they and then the Valkyries uh it's like
no we have we have to keep the humans
safe and they're they're good and blah
blah blah so the gods was like you know
what we're gonna get the best fighters
and also fight the best Gods so they
give uh like they bring out the best of
the best of the fighters they grab like
was it Musashi miyamo Musashi like the
the best Samurai the best sumo guy the
best like boxer
and they fight gods and some yeah
Hercules and [ __ ] like that it's a lot
of fun it's good [ __ ] it's a good Adam
yeah
Genesis yeah
Zeus what's it called what's it called a
wreck it's a rhino rock records of
Ragnarok yeah is that like a how to beat
thing how to beat Vibes it could be but
it's a lot of fighting
oh okay it's a lot of one fever so but
it's also a lot of history historical
stuff you can use to beat them out
okay
uh I can make a kill is also pretty good
what's the scissor one what is that is
that how can we go kill
or is akame gonna kill the the Dragon
one
the one the guy will recommend red
Garden number six
Universe paranoia I thought Tokyo
Adventure was already out Is this
different one took her Avengers out I
don't know what it I think
uh Tokyo Avengers also great
uh show a great
manga show it's still ongoing
they're going through things yeah
yeah
and
records of Ragnarok they fight uh
Heracles is that not Hercules Am I Wrong
any history guy Hercules
Heracles is basically here
or is it different people
because I might be different people but
I thought that it was Hercules versus
Jack the Ripper I thought that was the
it confuses the [ __ ] out of me wrong I
heard about it
yeah
Kelly is that talking about Hercules and
stuff just reminds me of like God of War
you know oh I know one of that oh it's
the same character but it's uh once like
Greek one's Roman it's like they call it
differently
correctly okay Hercules
bro I've played like two hours of the
new God of War so [ __ ] good
is it really it's so good oh my God the
opening
okay God of War favorite game
you know I would say I I don't have the
best tech gear but I heard like if you
have certain settings you can like
pump up the resolution or something even
better so when you do fight Thor it's
supposed to be like
super awesome or something I've heard
about that yeah
it's yeah it's a monitor I think it's
super epic I played the old one that was
pretty good
like one and three the other one's fine
yeah and like the PSP one too where you
had to do the thing with the joysticks
of course that one's being very pervy
he's thinking about he got work he's
thinking about the
thinking about that thing with what am I
think about
what is it for deity Aphrodite yeah you
gotta get through the game man
yeah how long did you stay on that part
here he kept replaying it
[Laughter]
oh goodness gracious weebs
I got nothing but how we doing how we
doing
you need more energy drinks then that's
true actually let me get one hold up
here you go get your energy drink
all right gosh so let's talk [ __ ] about
dog he can't hear us anymore
what do you guys want to know Secrets uh
you can you guys can ask anything about
Domin I'll tell you about it his bank
account uh
has no soul he will tell you
I have no soul so if you guys tip me
I'll probably uh uh do it uh welcome
back Tom how's it going
so we said nothing about you
hey
don't forget to hydrate people
oh
okay zen master 24 same person but in
that show the talk about records of
Ragnarok they use their Heracles version
but same character and to swindopot you
get to see Nikola Tesla versus Beelzebub
you know what would be a lot of fun when
they call Nikola Tesla Elon musion
it is [ __ ] Tesla X car oh it's like
the US oh did you see that I [ __ ] up
Twitter already
thank you
inspired so many people
yeah on a killing spree there
oh wait tell you what
let's see
people in the audience what is a
favorite anime of a video that we've
done that you like let us know and what
is the one that you thought was the
worst piece of [ __ ] ever go to hell you
know how to beat crew all that [ __ ]
everything's gonna give us brutal yeah
give us like both of those
what'd you say Bobcat or anything that
you wrote
shut up the worst
no it's great I liked all of them
they're all babies
what's everyone's favorite what's
everyone's least favorite if you guys
have worst piece of [ __ ] you know you
just watch it and like you taste like
disgusting your mind
it's a good one that's a good one
yes
they're making an anime series for it uh
they're making a new one really yeah
you know longer form fleshed out type
[ __ ] yeah
it could be really sweet I tell you what
those bears in Acura the the three
wrinkly old Benjamin Button kids were
like messing with his brain yeah making
them see stuff I that stuff I'm like I'm
like trying to tell hell like yo how
censor this stuff it's creepy he's like
it's not even real blood it's just
stuff on a giant bear milk because
they're kids
guys like having to try and like you
know blur out a ton of stuff for like
the anime and all that it's pretty tough
it's a lot of work and like some stuff
you don't know if you should kind of
blur out but you kind of do anyway just
to be safe but sometimes you don't it's
uh it's a whole thing the whole thing
and then we lose control yeah
my favorite is probably Japan since
great ah depends things oh that was so
sad though you know the dad dies like so
quick
everyone lost in that [ __ ] one kind
of yeah that's true depressing yeah
that's what would happen I would
probably be dead
I think I think I wrote a killer um last
line in that one I can't making a joke a
bad joke or something camera no I think
if it was it was a bad joke I'll
probably cut it God damn damn it [ __ ]
killing my babies baby killer
uh not in Texas
[Laughter]
I laughed at my own joke sorry it's like
a second later uh are great uh really I
don't live there so I don't really care
oh a great reason my favorites are high
school the dead another hikarashi Future
Diary course party all right magical
girl racing project
uh Goblin Slayer Goblin Slayer was like
such a [ __ ] fun one it was unique
because
the characters pretty much the whole
story was just them going on side quests
and shooting the [ __ ] like you know they
had the the threat of the mate the main
boss like the preparing for the like the
the main boss but he didn't really come
in at all throughout the whole season it
was just them like [ __ ] around
killing goblins that was a fun one
where'd she do the second season second
season out right
really
oh [ __ ] I'd be down would be fine simple
storyline too so like it you can like
really flesh it out you know kind of
like you don't have to keep track of
like 10 [ __ ] different things in
anime you got to keep track of a lot of
[ __ ] most
season two police state oh has not been
that's not out yet they have a movie
they have a movie they have a movie they
don't have a season two oh the TV show
Alice in Borderland guys that [ __ ] was
good you've seen that
[ __ ] man I wish they made an actual
anime for Alison borderline all right
it's such a they just made a short
version of Alice in Borderlands
uh that kind of sucked yeah yeah
don't be offended my least favorites
were the live action ones because
they're technically the master I love
you sure fair enough Beatrix fair enough
live action yeah yeah that's fair
a really good one to do is how to beat
Madoka Magica but isn't didn't we do
that one or is that a different one is
magical or racing magical Chrome erasing
project and Madoka Magica is different
things do you like the difference no
there's another one that's like super
dark where we have to we have to Center
ourselves I know it I've seen it I've
seen YouTube videos of it there's like a
magical girl one where the girl was
given the gift of magical but the girls
like life is [ __ ] up
so [ __ ] up the girl was uh uh was uh I
can't remember you you guys think High
School Ed served season two High School
the dead deserved like [ __ ] 10
seasons that's the last time I heard
about it I read the Manga great [ __ ]
it's a lot of fun it sucked that the the
writer one of the writer passed them
like passed away so they had to quit
while they're ahead uh they're like two
brothers who did like
oh [ __ ] damn logical introspection I've
just liked some of the anime you guys
have covered like Geo okay but that
wasn't because of you guys just the
anime being kind of weird yeah that is
weird I remember watching the anime and
I had no I had no fun
anime you guys covered like yo oh okay I
love you I love the book do I have the
book here no I don't uh show them you
weeb
I have Uzumaki uzumak is coming out soon
uh Uzumaki created by tsunamis I think
uh it's gonna come up with a good one
and we're gonna 100 gonna do that one
I agree high school health the dead
deserve more it came out at the right
time high school after that came out at
the specific time where zombies are big
that was like early Walking Dead 11.
yeah yeah something like that or 2010
Maybe but yeah
yeah
Gill was odd remember the cow like in
the sea of those like the fish Walkers
random [ __ ] [ __ ] at the end they were
just thrown in their mouth so why is
there a cow it is out it is after that
anime that I started like
like uh deciding to look up the anime
like story on like websites and [ __ ] it
was after that anime that I realized I
can't just rely on anime to tell the
story because sometimes the story just
don't make no [ __ ]
it's true
the [ __ ] up
all right that [ __ ] thumbnail huh how
giving a BJ or something it was great
that was great great thumbnail I'm gonna
get us kicked off of The Stream bro
if we um if we get to a million Subs at
some point I will get a Geo tattoo
somewhere I already decided so just
heads up stay tuned
that's true he did talk about that I
will actually get but like a cool one
not like a weird
oh It's gotta be the thumbnail no it's
Library [ __ ] right here on the cheek
no it's a trap step
oh
there you go
oh no no no no no uh is there any other
anime near to
High School the dead is there any other
enemy that's ask Camp yes high school
with the Dead
I don't know about that
think how I'm not sure about that one I
ain't the web expert just the weeb king
I don't know there's not a lot of good
ones uh yeah
ultimate I'm looking at zombie animes
all right
it's this zombie High School of the Dead
kabaneri School Life Soul station
gun gray Tokyo Ghoul I'm writing it down
Beatrix other side corpse princess all
right empires of the corpse empires of
corpses
zombie yeah yeah I think uh I think we
might already have that added on the
list Beatrice okay
School live it's like
I don't know is it zombie enough I don't
know
is that horrible enough that's school
life but uh we'll look into it we'll
watch it oh yeah someone suggested that
yeah I got the written
I think I think that would work
what is milder okay I feel like I'm
trying to sleep
so started no worries Beatrice
I see you get in a drink or something go
get a coffee
I'm jealous of you Griff [ __ ]
Thailand needs to get more energy drinks
man like it's got to get the whole Ross
so jealous
yeah okay y'all don't know but Dom loves
dare I say loves Monster Energy drinks
like
that is true
well I tried to send you Monster Energy
man you're not gonna like it's such a
waste
such a waste of money you can't you can
only buy the green one here you can't
buy like the sugar-free one like you can
do in America well one day though mango
town will will get we'll get this
right
uh survival all right we'll look into it
Beatrix
written no I'm actually gonna have a
blue shirt or a red shirt uh red shirt
all the way blue shirt
I just uh I think Richard people are
like Star Trek
oh that's funny a bunch of red shirts
[ __ ] die so easily berserk
hey Benjamin berserk yes I want to do
berserk so bad so bad but we'd have to
take our time on that one there's a lot
in there it's very dark
but
set in like a world where there's still
I think enough of reality in there that
we could really make some sweet how to
beat stuff I mean there's a whole heck
of a lot of fantasy especially in the
manga I just want to see the horse
no
is that the one the really long anime
it's not that though
uh it's not it's pretty long but not as
long as the rest of One Piece okay
um do you like G fuel I heard it's good
and better than energy drinks actually I
haven't tried bang or G fuel guys uh
it's not a that's an American thing I
don't think that's in Thailand otherwise
I would have sniffed it out
I want to try it
bang or what G fuel do you it's cheap
yeah g Fuel and bang energy drink but
they're not here yet guys
one day one day
Andy
care I'm sorry I've mispronounced that
love your work on Survivor or death game
based on anime preference and go to I
just love the video thank you thanks man
appreciate it
put you around there small house a big
house
depending on who how many people are
living see I would imagine a big house
it would get scary because you know it's
a lot of empty rooms that's where the
ghost didn't start to come and like you
know smaller place like this place is
pretty small my friends called the
shoebox apartment but like it's not
scary because it's not really big so
like there's no like empty hallways and
[ __ ] small house baby
uh we actually have done dangan drop run
by it was in
it was in way back it was in cinema
summary we did a collab with Cinema
summary
yeah so we posted it over there so you
guys can watch it on you know it's
really weird
what's weird people weebs it's really
weird people I did that video right I
did the recording I'm talking you know
with Chandler you know how to beat their
voice guy and I do it and they somehow
still thought that I was him I'm like
how my voice is nothing like him
all of the how to beat fans thought I
was him like your voice sounds weird but
great video I'm like
oh
that is funny
uh how about you if you didn't say that
uh
about add it to your into your channel
maybe we'll maybe you will in the future
um
okay
but
I can't remember what I was gonna say
well places are easier to clean also uh
would you do small places or big places
Griffin
um probably big because I mean you know
got another kid on the way and you know
I'm probably will need a you know
obviously I gotta find some place to put
them I can like put them in a shed you
know
as long as there's enough ventilation in
my right dog hey
that's my wife she's gonna watch this
and she's my wife oh you want to put him
in a in a shed and I'll be like well yes
I do
does your wife become Southerners
Skype
Chick-fil-A only because uh that's not a
thing here Chick-fil-A that'd be sick
McDonald's great no depend I uh I like
paw pies pop ice cream papa is better
than I don't know Chick-fil-A no I don't
remember that taste no way no Papa's
better all right 100 better
if you put the Popeyes chicken sandwich
Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A [ __ ] get out
bro
oh that's a lie guys if you've eaten
Popeyes and Chick-fil-A let me know
which one's better how can we pull how
do we pull on this [ __ ] chat how do
we do that that'll be cute actually do a
[ __ ] whole thing for random [ __ ]
it's got to be a way oh you know what
maybe when we do another one of these we
could like tell them like go to Twitter
you know we could put a Twitter poll you
know
and they could
how do you say Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A
that's a gift oh [ __ ] our first [ __ ]
thing he did he did it yes I'm so proud
of you that's so cute that's fun
actually I'm so happy no one no one's
doing it um come on
you did it oh shut the [ __ ] up dog
it's
oh meow 2K is also with you
and she does random accents like you
Griff oh it's Chick-fil-A everyone's
picking Chick-fil-A
yes I knew it I can't remember I can't
remember Popeyes to be honest
sorry Bobcat quitting the channel
then pick Popeyes
yes more people on my side don't do it
no more people on my side
Australia doesn't have either KFC's
probably like the best uh second option
but KFC in America sucks but KFC in
America sucks so much yeah I don't know
man it wasn't it wasn't great I don't
know I was expecting something like
Asian KFC is so much [ __ ] better than
any of what any [ __ ] in America Spore
What's um Claris what's uh four
or Singapore never watched ghost stories
but specifically the dubbed version if
not
stories I'm gonna look that up
is that a thing on no
I don't know what that is
good write it down criff
uh terraformers I've been trying to get
Domino to terraforms oh my God Beatrice
God he's being a big ass baby
all right the mutant cockroaches have
you seen them like
I know what she's talking about it's so
much fun maybe we'll do it one day
anyone who's watching and lurking in the
background if you pick Popeyes I'll
end the poll right now
somebody's actually coming up twice
I'm keeping my weeps come to me
do we watch anime outside of making
YouTube videos guys
guys
uh yeah not
not as much so now it's like our job so
that was just like
watching no one win on the video that we
do
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] 50 50. one last vote
guys one last vote come on one more come
on if Alby will appear in YouTube
stories if Popeye wins I'll take it all
right we're ending it right now
Chick-fil-A
it sounds like Chick-fil-A is winning I
don't know it's 50 50. no one's putting
in the vote we'll end it and we'll edit
it guys we need Bobcat on a stream can
we someone just it's 18 votes it's 18.
it's still 50 50. can someone put
Popeyes just I need to see Bobcat on a
YouTube store you don't ever it's been a
year okay somebody put please put
Popeyes one more oh
my God uh they haven't ended right it's
Tokyo Avengers has took your adventure
ended
up
collection we are planning to do that
but it's a lot of short stories and we
don't know how yeah Bobcat actually told
um told me about that uh earlier I
remember that that seemed pretty
interesting I'm down for that that's
fine it's Chick-fil-A guys I want Bobcat
to appear in a YouTube story make
Popeye's win I should have [ __ ] voted
okay oh it's 20. it's 50 50 again all
right that's fair
is good we're ending it at like five
minutes all right Bobcat will appear in
a YouTube store regardless no worries
with meowy 2K I got you yes
but no um I pretty much yeah I mean I
don't know like I don't really watch
anime outside of the thing just because
it takes up so much of my my day but you
want pretty much just five hour podcast
that is true I do that is true
I have a real problem
you're a real problem hypocrite
uh I think I think it's ending uh
Chick-fil-A's winning
take the knife in yes that's right
meowing 2K we got this
uh Claymore oh [ __ ] that would be fun
claymore's great I love Claymore
uh oh that would be fun do you want
anything jujito is great I love Tommy
Tommy is also good the common slogan
inclusivity Popeyes
yes we're winning
five minutes ago
it's like we're ending it now
like we're giving away oh [ __ ] yeah
Papa's just one all right we're gonna
see [ __ ]
on a YouTube story guys Mark myself it
takes about a week and probably
sometimes a week and a half to do a full
video too probably two weeks if you if
you actually no actually two weeks two
weeks for
uh one week of writing one week of
editing uh when we were writing probably
a couple of days for voice act doing
voice stuff for Griffin right Gruff and
then
uh one week of editing
and then we do that every week until we
die
uh pretty much do we know until you guys
don't want us to do it anymore I was
recently um I was talking to
Chandler about like how they you know
they're going like hard with all their
releases on the how to beat channel
right and you guys don't want to know
what they have to do to release like two
or three videos a week it is insane so
like for us just to release one video it
is so much work it is insane
but yeah it's pretty crazy that's for
sure
let's see
um oh yeah it's not anime what about
shows like Breaking Bad
never
we can cook blue meth better than they
do
because
uh oh yeah because apparently of making
it a blue color is making it impure
I've heard it from other people talking
about it hahaha
they're people
yes other meth dealers in my area okay
I'm about to log off soon hopefully you
guys do riddle story of the devil you
took note already big success thanks
thank you yeah
thank you thanks for stopping by I
really appreciate it do you have that
one riddle story of devil I do have that
uh but uh Griffin do you have Dave saw
chicken or do you not have Dave saw
chicken
you know we talked about this remember
when we were in la oh yeah we did yeah
guys if you haven't seen it go check out
our anime video which at some point we
will Air the podcast for that at some
point but um oh yeah probably more you
know because so but anyway so Al was um
you know Alan Dom have been we're in
California like film school right and
um
when I met up with him that was the
first time we had ever met each other
like in person we worked together all
this time but finally Solomon prayers
I'm like yes it was super exciting and
uh we went to this amazing Ramen place
and he told me about like this Apes
whatever was chicken or something I
can't remember what is it called Dave's
Hot Chicken
salad chicken he's like it is amazing
and I'm like I did I ever had it it
sounds great pop ice cream Dave's not
you and your Popeyes uh this is good I
love it
that's
more expensive than Popeyes which is
something that I don't like
uh we like we like cheap probably
what happened my comments are lagging
right now
I know no one's no one's typing no no
but like watching out for some reason
how tall everyone's way taller tonight
everyone's taller than I am yeah it's
[ __ ]
um like six four
I'm like 194 centimeters yes I think I'm
like six three I might I have to check
it might be six two
okay
uh you know I no offense to uh I thought
he was gonna be a lot shorter
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you dude
[Music]
I thought but then I when he came up
like whoa you're like you're tall you're
like you're way taller than me I'm like
no you're not you're not short told you
I'm like you're not short
backhanded compliment such a backhanded
confidence
there's a reason why the channel is
probably ending in like probably five
weeks
drawing uh we do I do love chainsaw
machine someone's a good one uh
everyone's way taller it's [ __ ]
five I'm like I'm encroaching to five
eleven I'm five tenth and seven eighth
it's [ __ ]
every time I checked they gave me the
seventh eighth it's just [ __ ] run up
this [ __ ]
he's six foot with heels no worries
um I knew somebody I used to work at
Subway and there was a girl her name was
Ally she was 4 10.
she was yeah
stupid loud like she had this laugh it
would like burst your eardrum oh my gosh
are you all planning to go to any
conventions this winter spring uh
probably no probably next year we'll
probably do anime yeah
yeah yeah it depends on if we'll be
there if Dom is able to come or not
because he keeps forgetting to do his uh
passport no now it's okay most likely I
can come
yeah I have some the whole thing guys
the whole thing
you're taller than Charizard so to our
tall Kings all right
patronizing funny okay
oh here's we should put a poll like
what's uh like their favorite uh Pokemon
I'd be curious
all of them
we we probably will make a Discord one
of these days just oh here's a good
question that would be fun actually
Mercy Minecraft
Inc Blaster what did we do before
YouTube
your mom
oh next question ah with the pause again
uh what you do graph what you do
which I do well I did a bunch of things
uh first I did a personal training for a
while and then uh
ballroom dancing like dancing with the
star stuff and then I got into
voiceovers and then YouTube
that's the really short version
what about you Bobcat repeat after me
something something Japanese he's a DS I
think what are you no I'm reading the
comments why did you guys uh well what
you do before
me before YouTube uh yeah
I know just watch YouTube
no I studied I started with you bro we
started filmmaking I worked in the I
worked in La a little bit for a year
after I finished school
uh try to be a scoring Rider uh and then
try to make a web series and that fell
apart
because everyone kept fighting with each
other that's true
yeah
and then I went home because of the uh
because of the pandemic
well no I went home before but and then
I was supposed to come back to LA but I
we got everything shut down so I stayed
home and then suddenly we did the
YouTube channel
true that's true
uh I did um
well I tried to do some sort of
screenwriting thing here with that uh
Housewives of Bangkok thing which
crashed and burned
um that might come out one day I don't
know if it is you weaves will be the
first to know and um think like um you
know Desperate Housewives but like
modern and like in Bangkok and like it's
all like cool and all anyway one day and
then um basically I did some acting and
modeling I was trash at least here and
then uh started
um developing my own like uh blog like
men's uh style blog doc you know website
type thing
and then uh using the skills I did with
that I started content writing SEO
writing and then somehow [ __ ] you
know writing and then boom I am the weeb
king
but are you speaking
Elise come on
we're gonna finish uh how do we Attack
on Titan we will
uh will you get will you make a video on
chainsaw man we will
uh
it's on the list
we keep saying oh we're gonna run out of
we're gonna run out of anime but
apparently we have a lot of [ __ ]
anime to watch that is actually um
low-key Bobcats uh concern we're like
we're gonna run out of anime at some
point and he's probably doing the math
right now like we have like point five
years such a smoking hot model such a
king
all right
yeah 2K I love you very sweet
oh that blah blah blah I don't know that
as you are already dead oh damn mean s
what's up
hey Danish
oh yes meowing 2K yes I did ballroom
dancing that was very fun taught it a
while it was a lot of fun
um one time me and my at the time it was
fiance that she went with me to one of
our dance parties because all the
clients for the the studio I was working
at they had these dance parties every
week and she came and it was a Halloween
party right and we had this one guy his
name was Ernie he's seven feet tall and
he's an engineer for the government
he came in as a as a carrot so he was a
seven foot tall carrot and then he walks
up to my fiance and he starts hitting on
her I'm like Ernie stop it oh what seven
foot Guy starts hitting on your girl
hey it's a seven foot government and he
came in his dress is a giant carrot
literally bro
it's like no
no oh that's hilarious what you do like
you like you know what you do
I'm like no he's like he goes well you
know if it doesn't work out you know
there's there goes [ __ ] and I'm like I
literally was like Ernie no there's no
chance or anything no he's like oh oh
Ernie all right
here's a question are you guys gonna do
more of these
probably
yeah I mean the goal is to do like this
quite often but more like this is more
of an informal type Q a thing but like I
guess we would do um we covered with
animes right for the usual weeks that we
do this stuff cover animes talk about
the anime we did
you know if you guys have any questions
answer it because we we would like to do
a live stream thing pretty regularly so
it gets you guys involved and all that
stuff damn star kid fill seven feet tall
plant lumbering around like a moving
salad Forest good dominance hit on the
giant carrot
it was something uh where are we all
three from guys Uno doughy Cruz welcome
back where are we all from gentlemen
weebs you start Tom
you're the most you're the most
interesting one
I'm half Indian half Danish raised in
mango Town sweet and sour Nation Bangkok
Thailand
uh you guys
he
I don't know what I am I'm a a mutt a
host of things I know I have a speck of
Cherokee Indians some German and some
english
and uh I live on the east coast of the
USA that is where I live
so uh Griffin address is at uh one one
one one
weed Vine Water Canyon we buy water
Canyon Avenue
and uh
uh I just I live in Indonesia
that's all you get to know currently
where all the all every world leaders is
here
that's true I saw that I'm like damn
Bobcat nice the cheats they're having
the G20 it's like oh yeah yeah
um I heard there's like a fleet uh what
no you're going there's a fleet of like
electric cars that picked up some people
what are we talking about the G the G20
uh
that was in Bali right yeah it's in Bali
yeah yeah
terrible place to hold it
you want to go to Bali that'd be cool
that would be sick but I don't have a
conference there you should do anime
conference there that'd be fun yeah that
would be cool actually traffic's
horrible bro
oh dude
Southeast Asian Kings hell yeah man I'll
tell you yeah
you guys already asked this how did you
guys meet and start working on this
together zen master a quick recap we all
did kind of our own thing and then we
met that's the real short version as um
let's see so I did like personal
training uh done with the Stars type
teaching stuff got into voiceovers Dom
and like some modeling stuff some like
SEO writing then he got into like
YouTube and Al kind of did was doing his
own thing for it I had film school and
then he kind of got the know the how to
be the anime gig so that's the really
condensed version but yes we have talked
about how we met before yes
what's up
it's a meme like anime me sort of stuff
oh makes sense
that went over man I'm like
oh no what else what else are you going
to how to be Jojo
that's a bobcat question
uh one of these things we'll probably do
one
uh Griffin secretly from the last he
literally [ __ ] that's actually
brilliant he does kind of remind me
now what's really funny so in high
school they did the you know
uh Wizard of Oz or whatever and I
actually I was the Scarecrow so it's
really funny that you mentioned that oh
nice yeah
that's
funny
it's too funny
you guys do any of theater stuff in high
school or not
I try to join a theater uh like
extracurricular uh yeah
uh theater uh then they said I wasn't
good enough getting the [ __ ] out so I
was like all right I'm sorry oh
hello welcome back hi
I did a what do you call it uh well I
didn't you know I knew theater had uh
was good to get into like acting and
[ __ ] man I [ __ ] don't tell the
teachers but I just hate theater man I
can't stand
like you just can't do it man I can't do
it but um yeah I tried on my plot I
tried out for Guys and Dolls way back
but I got a [ __ ] the background
singer dude wearing the Fedora type [ __ ]
not one of the main roles Unfortunately
they didn't realize I was the weed King
fedoras I remember you left LA because
you had to travel home because your
passport got [ __ ] over yeah and you
left your Fedora we just had it no it's
not a fedora man and yeah I left it and
then [ __ ] it was such a waste I
should have brought it with me why did I
because who I don't know where you left
it and I brought it with me oh no
because it wasn't mine it was uh
pusheen's it was uh it wasn't even mine
bro yeah but it's your Shrine so yeah
all right how does it arrive it's also
on our Channel you can watch it there
that was a good one
I wish they continued uh can't can't
such a good show such a good manga
that's good
a lot problem that problem buy me out UK
thanks for stopping by I was never good
at sports I was also not good at sports
it's all right we're pretty Gucci
oh uh no I played basketball
all the time and uh because for an age
and I'm pretty tall
and then I meet other people who's
taller and but usually I people when I
play people who are taller than me they
don't have [ __ ] good forms it's like
God damn they just use their height but
they're not able to you know play good
uh
so it doesn't matter if you can get it
in the net oh man
let's see it's about placement if you're
playing Center
uh I know Griffin I was in that
production with you plot twist I'm
kidding okay uh battle in five seconds
it's on the list I once played the role
of Snow White but I still regret
because the whole play was cringy that's
true that's pretty much all school plays
in general I feel like
it was a good time it was way up it was
super hot up there on the lights and
crap but and they [ __ ] work you like
dogs men like the teachers and [ __ ]
they're like coming every day and like
you got your homework and you gotta
[ __ ] spend five hours to do this
thing
it's true it is a thing our I felt so
bad for a lion or Cowardly Lion
I think her name was Nicole she
um we had a sweet like costume
department so they it was really like
high quality stuff but it was so thick
like she was like almost like
overheating all the time it was terrible
I was like oh my gosh
crazy have we played the new God of War
Al has and he blew up
I'm playing it it's two hours in if you
guys want to watch me play it you can
watch it on Twitch hey description hey
there it is the description on check out
the thing initial sense I play it
sometimes uh on my other channel called
Kent camp where I sometimes play games
uh with my other friends
you're selling it so hard right now yes
people can come if they want to if they
don't yeah it's pretty good guys uh stop
by guest appearance on there you know
yeah when the pink dumb out from the
group because Dom never showed up to our
uh now I gotta get back into it gotta
get back in I know it's been a year so
technically you're out of the group
start our kid Phil I was placed on the
basketball team because I was tall my
knowledge of basketball was slam dunk
anime I know that anime actually another
one hey there you go oh
they sound like
saying [ __ ] I think he's saying [ __ ]
we bought it I don't know I don't want
to get these nuts by [ __ ] Chatters
all right yeah sounds like a lick my
balls
yeah that's what happened having kids
and [ __ ] will do it yet man eventually
all right Griff
you could say he got harder am I right
being a father really changes you am I
right Griff
sure fun fact though you know they say
I don't know where I went this way but
anyways fun fact married couples
actually
of that are uh fun time then all right
that wasn't the question but all right
oh I've got to get a shootout for that
one
uh clip it and I'll ship it to mayana's
uh IG
it's like I don't know your husband's
being hella weird on stream
uh
you know uh you don't do how to beat
mainstream animes why well first of all
Naruto is way too long one piece way too
long
uh
we can't do dragon ball because
they really uh copyright strike the [ __ ]
out of Dragon Ball
guys copyright strike and stuff is a
menace for anime but
is a huge problem
such a challenge like every week like me
and Al like I'll go he'll make the video
and I'll review it we'll go back and
forth trying to make sure that
everything because we we would love to
show you guys you know the whole thing
and it's uncensored all
oriness but like
it can be tough we have to be like
really careful with how we you know show
certain things we've thought about doing
a patreon that is kind of a thing that
is in the works but at the moment it's a
little bit on the back burner but it's
something we want to do where we can
show you guys unedited videos and you
can just see what you know what we would
love to show you guys at some point
literally that's the dream impossible
but
ah
sure
uh how to beat for mainstream
but yeah it's like we do we do we did
one punch man that's pretty mainstream
we just said that was actually one of
the one of the fun ones also uh most fun
I had one punch man was fun
uh how to beat how to beat Rising Shield
hero I don't know Rising Shield hero is
pretty
is there is there a
is there a earthquake happening in Tokyo
or is that an anime
I think that's a anime
see
we are
it is I think so
yeah because it's called Tokyo magnitude
yeah
is it like Japan sinks part two
it could be
that would be pretty sounds pretty good
yeah all right we'll do it
we'll do it all right we'll put it on
the list put it on the list all right
put it on the list I got it all right no
worries have a good night Clarice thanks
for stopping by bye bye we'll catch you
in the next one yes bye bye so nice to
meet you wait what's it called say it at
the end of the video which is probably
going to be in half an hour or something
we've been going for probably two this
has been pretty good guys I'm actually
pretty uh why are you saying why why are
you saying why with artists
don't know people are just the same
because he wants to yeah he's trying to
any hints trying to get for the next how
to beat anime video we'll see at the end
okay cool very end good Varian will tell
you
um we'll see what happens
um
funny that's this is so much fun
I'm happy to meet everyone this is a lot
of fun you need a [ __ ] better
internet next time voice box man
I don't understand because you need to
go to a Starbucks or something set up
should I do it is so weird when we're
done I'm sure I will kind of try to help
me out with it because I don't get it
but everything like where I'm at the
internet should be perfect it should be
just like uh do a speed test on your
phone how fast is the test of
speedclaw.com
speedtest.net or something
tell me why
[Laughter]
tell me what go boom doing it
okay
um
what else well that's funny
funny
what else Bobcat what what did I do what
it do
waves did we do anything for Halloween
that recently or not recently whatever I
planned you know the initial plan was I
was gonna go as the weave King for
Halloween literally dress up in a suit
and a red cape or like a burger king
crown
but that plan fell through maybe it's
just not an actual costume though
oh Griffin's in a pose
nice
thanks for stopping by bye love you
bye-bye uh I just want to thank you all
for getting me into made in abyss and
other animes I love oh I love you
thank you yes you are very good boy evil
I was like the least weeb weeb there is
me and the best was probably one of the
the best ones that I watched in an abyss
was like really
sad that's the latest video it is so
season two is so sad what the [ __ ] yeah
I heard my soul that was like so stupid
like the kid is like deteriorating into
like uh
oh we should we do I do want to do lost
Village I think we talked about it like
a while ago and I don't know why we
uh we didn't do it what is that sounds
sounds like a couple of kids go to a
village and they started going missing
oh [ __ ] I'm pretty good is that on there
oh that's on the list it's not on the
list but you write it on the list oh
my list
kids and Luggage be like
what
it's late I I'm having anime anime to
watch
king of sad have y'all watched the
sadness
sadness what's up
so the enemy
can I beat it
it's a Taiwanese body horror film oh
write that down oh it's a film
ain't you I think so
in by Canadian ratter crab sound pretty
good boss jabbit oh okay we can't do
this one
oh we can't
I mean it's a it's a live action
um
yeah those don't do so well guys
it's weird sometimes we'll do live
actions and it'll like do up ceiling
well like uh the korosensei video we did
oh yeah like on a whim like hey let me
try it and then just blew up I'm like
well then yeah I can't make the logic
behind that one I think after the last
few months it didn't work out so I think
we're just gonna be sticking to anime
that's fair that's fair uh silence
undying is it harder to review anime for
how to beat when it has a more obscure
story or Flop
[Music]
um
yeah I mean if there's more for me to
interpret then a lot of the times I'll
find myself going to like third party
sources to see like you know what people
have
commented that you know what you know if
there's a lot of it room for
interpretation that doesn't make sense
in the anime I'll find myself looking at
like different websites for what other
people think you know happen in the
store so yeah you know it does it does
take up more time
because I don't wanna
infer something you know too too
different than what the the artist of
the you know anime intended
that's a very good answer
with the words
I tune out after like the first few
seconds since
that love and robots you know that would
be so fun I loved uh love death robots
love that robot it's good good [ __ ]
uh too short for a how to beat anime
yes
[Music]
I really do heartbeat of Evangelion
would be so cool that's also one of the
oldies
that is an oldie an oldie but a goodie I
think the series just ended with the
last movie right how to uh Evangelion
3.0 plus one
it's a weird way of titling title it's a
weird title to do so Evangelion three
plus one or something like that
okay
hmm
comment in here
gotta be coverage yes the rebuilds uh
yeah I don't know uh
it's the same feeling that people said
about Final Fantasy 7 and final 7 remake
uh because it's a new thing a new
something happened multiverses and [ __ ]
or something like that I don't know what
what's it about
but yeah
I feel like this is a good place to end
the stream guys oh
all right sure
bobcat all right uh but yeah I mean this
is a pretty good [ __ ] first first
thing you know you guys enjoy the stream
yeah do you guys like it do you like it
yes you like your answers you like
Bobcat you know with his name Bobcat
Griff story about his marriage stuff
like me and my suit
marriage stuff in his suit
we did good high five weeps Albion is
short that's true start get Phil I'm not
gonna pump the brakes on that I'm gonna
be on his ass
I got you
uh you can't find me you can't find me
anyway so get [ __ ] ooh
ouch it's got you there we'll see we'll
see uh hopefully uh you guys come back
we uh we'll probably do this one again
soon ish we'll see
uh next week is Thanksgiving for Griffin
so probably won't do next week or we
just skip Griffin next week so we'll see
what happens [ __ ] all right uh we'll
probably do it in two weeks or something
yeah
girlfriend's gotta get that Black Friday
deal you know
oh it's like Friday where's the power
thanks for stopping by bro
thank you for being here I joined three
minutes ago it was still good
that's great hey you can always uh
subscribe to the channel like the video
like this video yeah I appreciate it uh
I'll give you a hint because I don't
know oh yeah next anime hint true yeah I
will not tell you what the anime is
about but I will tell you
like a hint for it
uh
the this is live Sean Tyler lonster
hello welcome welcome Sean James is this
pre-recorded no this is a very live
thing right now uh we just know who you
are Sean James who lives in somewhere in
the United States of America
if I got it wrong I'll die
[Laughter]
uh but yeah uh the next what's again
hint what's a good what's a good anime
hint okay [ __ ] I don't even know how
to give it a hint about anime bro uh
it's a looping Island
think about it
oh [ __ ]
looping Island baby here you go is that
a good that's the hint that was pretty
good actually I think if they really
think about it all right cool it's a
Lupine Island all right looping Island
think about it think about it locking in
your head
and thank you for coming uh don't forget
to like subscribe comment check out the
horrible
uh
yeah thank you everyone for coming by
we'll probably do it thank you guys
all right talk to you guys later I love
you my weebs
we'll see you next time
bye
[Music]